they were the centerpiece of the 1964
World's Fair exhibition in New York the
observation towers once a bold vision of
hope in the future now after decades of
neglect a crumbling relic of the past
but a new plan aims to update the towers
for the 21st century
I am excited by this I'm excited that
the excitement was catching and that
other people felt it too and understood
the historic historical concept of
making sure that this New York State
pavilion was saved that had become a
tourist attraction for people from all
across the world the renovation in
Flushing Meadows Queens is projected to
cost twenty four million dollars and is
expected to be complete in the spring of
2021 the work will include waterproofing
the basis of the towers stair
replacements electrical upgrades and
conservation work it never would have
happened without conservationists who
campaigned tirelessly for the overhaul
and in recent years did their part to
help even chipping in to repaint the
former New York State pavilion next to
the towers see history come back to life
and see the park sort of you know regain
a great icon and a great asset we
couldn't be happier we couldn't be more
excited offer ourselves personally but
for everybody who's gonna stand to
benefit this for generations to come
the groundbreaking ceremony was attended
by politicians and by people who took
part in the 1964 World's Fair it's a
long time waiting you know it's gonna be
in stages and I hope to be around long
enough to see it all done but there's so
much potential here there really is
people cared people were interested and
they cared and they said no we're not
gonna let you spend money to tear it
down we'd rather spend money to fix it
and preserve it and protect it and bring
it back to life even once the renovation
is complete the observation tower will
remain off-limits to visitors at least
for now the hope is it will be a beacon
drawing people to this far corner of the
city for a glimpse of its forgotten
glory
giving a new generation a chance to
create their own memories of the towers
christened salumi al jazeera New York